bonjour être accueillis en français ou
en anglais
peu importe pour shannon et ses amis je
préfère en profiter mais j'en suis
encore à régler sa folie
sauf que je lui parle en français moi ça
me dérange pas parce que nous
travaillons à parler anglais français
merci que pour d'autres adhérence mais
que je m'entends si je parle en français
tu me réponds en français ces jeunes
cégépiens confirme la tendance observée
par le frys québécoise de la langue
française pour 2017
si presque tous les commerces assure un
service en français le bonjour à y ait
de plus en plus répandue sur l'île de
montréal
moi j'encourage bien sûr c'est que nous
nous commerçants utilisent bonjour
points
alors au final je pense qu'il faut
s'assurer qu'elle est peut-être plus de
temps pagne de sensibilisation faut
valoriser notre langue notre langue
française bonjour merapi est ce que je
pourrais avoir trois chocolats dans une
voie pour remporter 6
en boîte et chocolat chauds souvent
polyglotte les jeunes s'adaptent à leurs
interlocuteurs
même si la charte de la langue française
leur accorde le droit d'être informés et
servis en français
ces entrepôts wade fait c'est en
français en fait à montréal les jeunes
québécois vivent leur quotidien dans les
deux langues
on parle français mais si tu t'en augnet
du formol à draguer mais la boisson
l'économie anglaise semprun on peut rien
y faire
comme nous mêmes on est dans une école
francophone ou logiciels à l'école ils
sont certains en anglais malgré
l'omniprésence de la culture anglophone
pour shannon le québec doit rester
francophone il faut quand même pas par
une autre partie francophone passé ce
qui fait qu'on est une province unique
au canada
votre québec de 2050 2060 vous le voyez
comme un messie qu'ils auraient besoin
l'angle plusieurs connaissances
les mélanger suspense maintenant y
mélanger je pense pas être encore plus
mélanger ici marie josée paquet comme on
radio canada montréal